there's another child's bike you know
what you guys thought we were cowards
you're giving us like little kids yeah
you're giving us baby bikes what are
these baby bikes for
hi i'm young gravy and i'm dylan francis
today we're going on gq's shopping spree
so let's get it
[Music]
first one up is hot tubs
you're proficient in hot tubs i love hot
tubs guys this one's a deep therapy tub
it's like a great bucket this one
honestly is good for you because
of the height eight bands is a little
bold but uh oh my god the next one's 50
bands i'm liking this one a lot um
michael phelps mp momentum deep swim spa
that's a mouthful you can swim and tub
at the same time yeah you can pull hot
tub
45 adjustable jets for hydrotherapy and
that's that's a lot you know in my house
growing up we had a hot tub basically
like in the back of the kitchen like
it's literally like in the side of the
kitchen it's ratchet it's like a 80s
house it fits like a person and a half i
like this one i'm already convinced yeah
the
motor powers the boat
up to five miles per hour damn my
question though is do we have to dock
this anywhere see i'm i'm concerned
about the five miles per hour it feels
like it's not really a boat at that
point that's slow it's a canoe i like it
but i i still feel like the phelps one
is is better but i'm i'm kind of on this
one so let's this one's kind of nice
this heart-shaped inflatable tub for 85
bucks i mean it's collapsible you can
put it away if you don't want to use it
anymore it's got four air valves how
much money do we have we gotta add as
much as much as we want but we can only
choose one we can't have two
on the other one we'll do the hot tub
boat hot tub
please
so next is headphones this is definitely
a big me category since
i'm a dj i'm a rapper i use headphones
the nova h1 gold audio earrings for 760
dollars these are kind of sick looking
i'm not gonna lie real pearl and gold
plating available in stutter clip-on
so that goes on your ear i mean that's
kind of a flex if you're just walking
around playing music out loud so
vibrating and i guess the vibration of
the sound
a lot like you know it's like one of
those pools where you go underwater and
you can hear the
the music all right next super mask
headphones and face masks 2.99 is that
will i am
i think
really good like
forehead recognition i can't tell you
always no you can always tell from the
glasses he loves wearing those like dr
octopus glasses all right these are 2.99
and it's developed by will i am i just
feel like whenever i see someone who's
wearing like one of those really like
industrial looking masks it's someone
who makes me uncomfortable i think we
just passed completely because i feel
like we're looking at this
all right sorry will i am
you're a cool dude and i really i really
[ __ ] with your music i hope you're
watching this sony neckband speaker
150 bucks this is weird directional
speakers for price so it's basically
saying it's directional because it's
around your neck so it's directional but
it's like playing out loud oh you have
privacy because it's playing directly at
your face but like
it's kind of i feel like you're going to
kind of be playing out loud it's like
that one kid in in high school yeah
you're like yo shut the [ __ ] up i don't
know kind of feels like shape ups of
headphones
okay bose frames tenor for 250. so
they've got bluetooth speakers that are
embedded in the sunglasses frame
polarized lenses and motion activated
controls i think this is doing too much
headphones with the sunglasses it's like
it's like the oakley's
i just could see this going into the
wrong hands like yeah into like the
the tuckers that are driving a f-150 you
like the earrings the earrings the
earrings it is easy
earrings for 760 dollars we'll take them
yep deal
all right cameo okay so we're now we're
gonna buy cameo from somebody oh it's
the app where you you pay some money to
to get someone to like wish you happy
birthday or tell you that you're like a
good person oh there's refresh right
there oh damn okay 85 bucks
175 tier for for businesses so
if we wanted him to promote a business
that that's pretty good rebecca black
friday you guys are [ __ ] the wrong
people these are like my good friends
i'm already leaning towards rebecca okay
almost 500 bucks that's that's a lot oh
vanilla ice though vanilla ice for 3.99
it's vanilla ice he'll give us a
personal video thirty thousand dollars
tier for businesses though we have
unlimited money so if we want to drop
thirty thousand dollars on vanilla do we
have a drop thirty thousand dollars we
don't have a business together though so
i think i feel like any of the business
to your stuff start one do you want to i
want to drop 30 bands on vanilla ice all
right tempted
lindsay lohan
how's lindsay lohan 500 and rebecca
black is 500 as well you're
underestimating rebecca black right now
dude am i yeah i think vanilla ice is
i'm leaning towards that vanilla ice we
want to start a business and spend 30
vans on vanilla yeah yeah i like that i
like that okay cool
all good options though yeah it would
have been rebecca black if we didn't
choose vanilla ice
next up is mattresses i'm in the market
for a mattress right now so you want so
this is perfect so we should actually
find one for you
in real life
right here
all right so this is really cool looking
black vinyl king waterbed for 1137.76
i'm into it because of the because of
how many of the print now the the animal
print on it is pretty cool and i like
the leather sort of bed frame yeah
print guy so they got i've never had a
water bed so so i'm i'm already kind of
sold yeah this and this reduces body
pressure and gives you comfort and a
better sleep supposedly well i guess we
have more options but it's an all wood
frame with soy based foam cushioning
which i know you're you're vegan we have
soy based foam cushioning i'm i'm almost
there yeah almost ready let's let's keep
let's go to the next one circular
two-sided
king
10-foot medium
memory foam mattress
so it's pretty much two thousand dollars
this is kind of my vibe i'm i'm tempted
it's ten feet
across it seems like so you can fit a
lot of people in there it's a good vibe
i'm into it okay you loved it reading
german so this is the hosting's grand
vidius
506 thousand and nine hundred ninety
dollars you know this one is crazy
mattress for 500 bands crafted with wool
cotton and horse hair horse hair the
first one was bought by drake i like
horses i just don't like the hair yeah i
don't like the hair like i feel like i
have a horse hair comb and i don't want
that in my bed
our bed our bed yep our bed it's cool i
can tell that it's kind of sexy and
there's a lot of good things here but
really i don't really know why it's
worth that much money we've got a jade
mat for 300 here so jade stone mats can
reduce symptoms of chronic disease
alleviate pain and revitalize skin this
feels like a crystal girl thing yeah
feels like i don't i don't believe that
my mom would have already told me about
this too because my mom is like so into
crystals and stones yeah me too i never
heard her say jade stone one time but i
think we're we're circular circular
two-sided king ten foot medium memory
foam mattress 199.99
yeah we're on that one
all right we're going with real estate
now
i love looking at home so
this is going to be good this this is
where we might conflict but i don't know
maybe not yeah yeah yeah beverly hills
mansion for 54 million dollars it's got
seven bedrooms 14 baths spiral staircase
water wall 150 year old olive tree from
italy it sounds kind of like all of like
the
la cool houses that people end up buying
the kitchen is not my favorite what is
it yeah i feel like i'm gonna run into
the counter and like hurt yourself hurt
myself so i'm not sold not so 54 meal is
crazy for a house yeah but we got it we
got a limited money so we can yeah we
could do that whoa oh okay yo french
alps chalet i'm already kind of tempted
my family lives in the alps a lot of my
family was in switzerland so we could
pull up on my
my family and whatnot go skiing this is
hidden way harder than the last one for
me the property is totally autonomous so
water catch systems turbines solar
panels
means the water is going to taste like
ass it's gonna be one of those places
where the water tastes like sulfur you
know solar panels are gonna run out of
wi-fi and like energy and all that yeah
but maybe the next one is like what type
of water do you want to get delivered to
your house i i like this phelps uh
chalet deal it's it's cute but i
probably just you know stop being
autonomous i'd respect that but i'd get
my own water you know i don't want my
water to smell like dookiehole all the
wood's heated yeah we love kind of
scares me though because what if the
house just explodes you sick
haunted rhode island farmhouse can we
skip this one
oh we're over it we're over it we're not
in there's we're so something allegedly
haunted by bethesda sherman a satan
worshiping baby killing a witch all
right dude i don't know why this was
even i hate everything about it i'm
already scared there's a shotgun above
the dining table
rochester minnesota craftsman house dude
all right so
someone did some research we got my
hometown you know what this would be so
funny if that was like your mom i
thought maybe it was gonna be my crib at
first honestly so we got a rochester
minnesota craftsman i mean it's a good
price it's 5 25. you got your kids going
to a nice elementary school a nice
middle school right here if we have kids
they're going to a good at school we're
having we're having a kid we're having
we got four bedrooms so we're having
kids i'm not really into this i don't
know all that either
we gotta make it the wallpaper yeah the
wallpaper is not really my thing but you
know what it's that's easy to fix so we
have unlimited money and we're only
spending 525 for this so if we're wrong
with rochester the mayo clinic is their
biggest hospital if anything [ __ ] up
happens so so true fellas you got that
uh-huh we got like eight quick trips i
would either do the french alps or the
the broadcast i'm glad that you're
interested yeah i think we go with the
with the chalet the french alps chalet
okay yeah i like that and then we
changed the water i had to show some
love to rochester but we're going with
the french jelly yeah
all right next up is vehicles all right
so first up we got mini mail carrier
with tent
319 dollars and 99 cents this is a a toy
okay
i thought it was an actual mail trucker
i was looking at the price and i was
like dude i need one
okay
i thought i was gonna i was like dude
i'll [ __ ] deliver some [ __ ] right so
it's a ups mail delivery truck right on
toy and it's perfect for the sidewalk
backyard and your driver you put your
feet through the yeah flintstones oh my
god dude i i
i'm too i've always been too tall for
those even since i was a kid i'm gonna
be i'm gonna be too tall for this too
next up is jeep go-kart for three
thousand two hundred dollars do you
think they make more powerful ones i
really want one of these this is sick if
it's only three bands like i'd need one
of these just for like cruising around
the neighborhood adult supervision is
required at all times okay so massimo
super size trail bike this one looks
like it's going to actually fit you know
i could fit on the back up to 200 pounds
i can't do it i weigh 215. oh [ __ ] all
right then it's out we're over it we're
over it peg
pergo is that how you say it i think we
go for the coke we're all with the
go-kart right the jeep go card and we'll
figure out how to make it work we'll
sauce it up or something yeah yeah go
kart for um 3 200 i got an armenian
homie who could definitely sauce it up
yeah i want to get some spinners we got
hurt feelings because you offered us all
children's cars but that's okay because
we think we're babies and we're not okay
next time we come in here though we want
to see real vehicles okay i mean i kind
of did want the mail truck though thanks
gq we appreciate y'all for the shopping
spree yeah everybody watching we just
dropped the ep called kicking cognac
hitters on there baby yeah check it out
all right we're gonna go drive our uh
go-kart so you did that
[Music]